[Music]
what did you do this weekend Diana me
nothing very interesting the world
remains in mourning after the death of
the Superman he said the age of heroes
who never come again
it has to
[Music]
we don't have anymore time
something is coming
nature gives you
no language
[Music]
the Kryptonian
[Music]
which made before
like all the others one this is the days
where mom's biggest concerns were
exploding windup penguins
this is crazy honestly I think we're all
gonna die
each of us in some way is held back
don't engage alone putting this together
it's really cool you guys seem ready to
do battle and stuff I've never done
battle
relax Alfred I'll take it from here uh
do I know you
Superman was a beast into the world
you don't save people
to see the best parts of themselves
oh I don't recognize this way
we all have to recognize
seven
[Music]
how many of you are there not enough do
you really think this oh wow they just
they really just vanish huh oh that's
rude
you said you've come now let's hope
you're not too late
so much has happened since I saw you I
lost my hammer like yesterday so that's
still pretty fresh
and then I went on a journey of
self-discovery I love you
[Music]
Wow you have no idea
hello the goddess of death has invaded
house god oh I missed this
and you and I have fibers thing did I
win no I want easily since I'm right uh
that's true
as God is dead we'll be reborn in my
image I thought you'd be glad to see me
need a stopper here now to prevent
Ragnarok the end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
like the old days
surprise this would be such fun
hi
he's a fighter
I'm not a queen or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
[Music]
we're the same you and I just a couple
of hotheaded fools yeah same old like
fire door like water mama kind of both
like fire but whole like raging fire so
I like smoldering fire the thing about
war is it only works if both sides to
leave they're the good guys the truth is
we're not so different
we fight to get back what was once ours
[Music]
but in the end and this is the end it's
just a city you'll get used to watching
them fall like we're safe for now we
need to figure out our next vote so
there's no next move and there is no we
what is that we're not here to eat those
pork not on the shrimp oh this guy's got
pork god you're Meriden I'm not looking
for Super Friends it doesn't matter
can't fight these people
not even with whatever it is your hand
can do it's cheap it's not they're
hunting our friends our family
and I'm not gonna stop there
[Music]
Marquez's coming
and the only thing keeping Manhattan for
crumble into a pile of dust was the four
of you the wars are New York it's over
not yet
[Music]
eyes ears performance I can see you've
formed a kind of bond
I promise he was temporary
electron they will disappoint you
Jessica like you're not
they're together
that we found each other I'm not hugging
you it's been a long week
[Music]
I was born in 2025 but I wish I'd grown
up in the 1980s like all my heroes I
live here in Columbus Ohio and 20:45 had
still ranked the fast destroying city on
earth but sure doesn't seem like it when
you live in the stacks
they called our generation than missing
millions missing not because we went
anywhere there's no more left to go
nowhere except the Oasis
it's the only place that feels like I
mean anything
a world where the limits of reality or
your own imagination
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you mean
[Music]
a mom um can we talk about so when you
guys got together was dad always an evil
warlord okay well here it is I got
sucked up he had so many plans who swim
vicious he said he wanted to concrete
the boys I thought it was a figure of
speech but if I had never met Garmadon I
would have never had you
Hey
[Music]
costas beer students are to need your
nose and when to fight and when to plant
in the shadows
unbelievable Garmadon
Lloyd that's right and it's Lloyd dad
[Music]
[Applause]
it's okay Lloyd nobody's parents are
perfect yeah but I feel like there's
more to Garmadon that I need to know to
understand your future you must go back
to your ninja roots your dad was a ninja
- Lloyd you hear that we don't waken the
unstoppable beast
the outfit are you ready to risk your
life for ninja go ninja go
I haven't felt this good in a long time
no noise are you okay yeah yeah I think
I think there's my arm is bad I wanna
look a scale of 1 to 10 to help that is
it oh I'd say it's about a 7-point arm
ripped off this film is not yet rated we
gotta do this let's engage
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys you see
okay
nothing's when we go back to the way
that it was
[Music]
not really we saw something
[Music]
No
I felt it
[Music]
darkness falls across the land the
midnight hour is close at hand creatures
crawl in search of blood to terrorize
y'all's neighborhood never shall be
found if you still see
must stand and face the hounds of hell
right inside a corpses shell
whoever's happening
is spreading from mrs. Grayson
[Applause]
directors please give me something
[Laughter]
we're from the Kings montañés shop in
London maybe you've heard of us
today marks the beginning of a new age
but I'm gonna show you to the Kingsmen a
bit of us say the world situation here
welcome to Statesman your American
cousins will be working side by side
let's get started
we've got brains skills skipping-rope
[Music]
to lasso whatever
[Music]
it's very American
[Music]
manners maketh man do you know what that
means you're looking for you what are
these what if I told you there's a place
where people have powers like us city of
Adeline and I can take you there
we're in humans maybe I'm foolish maybe
I'm blind see through this behind
brother sooner or later the humans are
going to find us got no way to prove it
so maybe the first course of action will
be to try to destroy one
I'm only human we need to go to hurts
now we need to strike first of all it
would only lead to war are you speaking
for yourself or for our King
[Music]
Maximus is trying to take over aniline
are you going to kill your only brother
I have to runner me as your new king
half the road don't put the blame on me
never don't put your blame on me you're
just a human they're the greatest
stories ever told
[Music]
hero show us we don't need to be perfect
to do what's right it's not about living
without fear but facing injustice
[Music]
it's not about being powerful but
finding your calling
least expected they show us it's okay to
be vulnerable
you made it how tough you are because
even though the heroes is still human
[Music]
discover the greatest stories never told
only on Netflix looks like I got here
just in time
why is there faring the berthing area
ferry lives don't matter today
that's it right there I took a little
homie out LAPD style like you do oh and
now you keep doing all your gangster
stuff I'm just trying to sell my house
don't worry about that everybody's just
trying to get along and have a good life
all of the races are different
just cuz they're different doesn't mean
anybody better or worse than anybody
Hey yeah where's the diversity I got a
dude in my car I didn't ask for it but
the whole world is watching
okay you don't like things I'm not here
to be your friend I need to know if [ __ ]
I bought that you got my back can't hide
it would goodness have physical towels
like the face
what's my face with you and it needs a
lot more conjugal love Terry do not wink
at me like that
we Adam not show us in room
certainly way for the cafe we are the
cavalry what is
that's magic
it's like a new killer weapon that
grants wishes that's whatever you want
I'm gonna be taller or shorter you want
10 million dollars you're not stealing
that why
[Music]
you gotta get out of this neighborhood
you're gonna kill you tell me and that's
what a super just gonna start magic
water we have to secure it
Milty stout of the Academy no they do
not
you're gonna keep Connor wait let's do
it
nine days I can't get out of my head
that's just the dark side
[Music]
we might be the promise you're not in a
prophecy we're gonna stolen Toyota
Corolla
another game's simple best ones are you
want to birthday
play by the rules may identification on
the victim
how's the piece but she's been dead the
tables this was on the body the truth
will set you free
[Music]
[Music]
I'm chasing a dead man
[Applause]
little guy
[Music]
the blood under the fingernails of our
victims John Kramer's jigsaw killer
that's impossible
[Music]
no that's not creepy at all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what is a Jaeger
the Jaeger is the pinnacle of human
invention when the monsters came we did
not wait for heroes to fall from the sky
and save us we saved ourselves
innovation is our superpower
what is it it's you times a thousand
tall as a mountain
with a beating heart that burns is
bright
[Music]
labeling us on to become the most heroic
version of ourselves
join the Yaga uprising
[Music]
[Music]
shall we begin
okay relax like you're asleep you're
sleeping you're dreaming of some eight
foot tall demon looking [ __ ]
oh yes a dream I like that
dreams are places you can have fun right
it's all in your mind so why not enjoy
it Shh listen go and check it out
[Music]
now we could in this dream of yours take
care of a situation like this we just
put Kenny's name down and see what
happens
I know you want to go on help her I
don't know it then it's a good thing you
go to bed
good now as long as we're playing let's
do right there's no need to stop it oh
oh sorry you what else is there Wow for
piggy not bad at all
now watch
[Music]